2人の男が同じ日にビットコイン取引を
始めました。1人は毎日12時間も
チャートを見つめ、わずかな上昇にも
飛びついていました。昨夜、たった1つの
クジラの罠で彼の全財産が清算されました。一方、
もう1人の男は家族と夕食を楽しみ、
ぐっすり眠り、翌朝目覚めると
5,000ドルの利益が出ていました。違いは
運ではありません。システムです。1人は
ハンターで、もう1人はディフェンダーでした。多くの
トレーダーが失敗するのは、彼らが
クジラのゲームをしているからです。買えと言われれば
買いますが、クジラはすでに罠を仕掛けていて
あなたは獲物なのです。Trap Defence BTCは
見えないものを可視化することで
ゲームを変えます。私たちのエンジンは
機関投資家の操作を事前に察知し、
あなたの損益に影響が出る前に知らせます。私たちは
究極のトレードスキル、つまり確率があなたに傾くまで
安全に待つ「規律」を提供します。
これはハイリスク市場のための高精度ディフェンスです。
そして今日、あなたはこれを
無料で手に入れられます。今すぐ
Defenders Academyに参加して、
Trap Scoreのミニマル版を
無料で受け取ってください。カード不要、無駄なし、
市場の“生の真実”だけを届けます。
獲物になるのは終わりにしましょう。ディフェンダーになり、
下のボタンを押してボットを起動し、
無料アクセスを今すぐ受け取ってください。